fast moving cars should have been a clue
some small arms fire there don't have to
go very far to find the fighting we're
right on the outskirts of done yet
scanned as you can hear there's a battle
going on we came to this bridge to film
some of the destruction caused by the
war what we didn't realize was we're not
entirely outside of the battle zone
you're not a ste see the stadium sure
not nice t turns out i'm standing on a
tank parked just under the bridge a
fighter off-camera trains his gun on me
and tells me not to move picture he
wants to check our documents special
special satisfied with our papers he
relaxes and we're free yeah well here we
go next day we returned better prepared
the flak jacket your helmet here last
but not least fresh battery
this is this be possible but it does
whatever little bigger we're being
driven to the Donets International
Airport the most fought over a piece of
real estate in the entire war by a
pro-russian fighter who goes by the
nickname Crimea to get a sense of what
lies ahead to truces have collapsed
already Crimea Thanks this one will to
travel sector gelateria and in battle
Nuada capacity Oh Tamina terrible
negatory with my work he says a
Ukrainian militia that enjoys a
billionaires backing is shooting at them
right now he wants to show son is gonna
keep just am Kipkay keep a low profile
could be snipers Vince 12 it woman
exactly a Capri da wannan Lydia one
sketches let's Tom State versatility
really battalion me premiere email or
this 3gs let see literally but
eliminated here to perceive Edith way
way way more attack the Bravo
a series of strange moments awaits its
international women's day big holiday
here and Crimea and the fighters have
come with gifts for another member of
the separatist Vostok battalion that are
quite would be my mom much yet I thought
was listed on me Ukraine spent hundreds
of millions of dollars building the
airport danielles was about to host the
European soccer championship the country
wanted to show the world it too could
have a first-class airport it's now a
wasteland it's only value is that of a
buffer
this is utter destruction and I've been
in demolition sites war zones I've never
seen anything quite like this it's not
every day you see an armed personnel
carrier in an airport terminal it is
more than clear no one is going to fly
here for a very long time the
apocalyptic scenes go on and on and we
didn't even see all of it half of the
airport is guarded by another battalion
with its own chain of command just like
the Ukrainian side the fighters over
here aren't always on the same page
we're going to stay a little crispies
had a burst of gunfire but the Ukrainian
position the other side of the front
lines is just about 2,000 meters that
way Ukrainians have set up and a coal
mine at the top of the elevator shaft
the idea of rebuilding this Airport with
the two sides so close still shooting
one of their even if it's only sporadic
and occasional is unthinkable
we visit Ukrainian troops on the other
side of the front lines this soldier
lost his friend to a separatist shell
one will kill was against dewasa it
blows up in the air and drop shrapnel
and our brother the only boy with a flak
jacket was the one that died
it's easy to see how this conflict might
explode again there are tens of
thousands of miners with nothing to do
plenty that I've already taken up arms
there are also plenty of weapons moving
around how would you know whether
they're being withdrawn or just moved
for another day fire power and firewood
essential ingredients in wintertime
warfare it's no surprise historians call
this part of the world the blood lens
I didn't meet a single person on either
side who thought the fighting is over
that includes a commander from the bus
stop battalion if lil if you analyse the
previous truces that were announced by
our side or their side ukrainian side
uses the true story organized the truth
get it and then it starts again with
fresh troops that's what happened in the
summer and fall I'm afraid that's what
will happen again right around the
corner we bump into another reminder
this is war a group of men are
resuscitating a fighter just hit in a
mortar strike but they lose him the
outlook for eastern Ukraine is bleak I'd
hate to see what a return to the
fighting might look like
you